the next app on this list actually
changed my life for the worse it didn't
change it for the better however there
is a way that you can change it for the
better without actually having to
terminate that app completely so the app
i'm talking about is outlook and outlook
obviously is just a simple mail client
that continuously just sends us
notification after notification enough
notification and it gets rather draining
but basically what i've implemented is a
focus mode for personal and work mode so
whenever i want to have some personal
time to actually work on things that i
need to achieve be it going to the gym
being eating healthy meal prepping or
doing anything in between even something
as simple as just relaxing i have
personal mode turned on so none of those
distractions come through and it
actually allows me to be present in that
moment rather than focusing on what the
distractions are coming up on the phone
if you want to see the full video and
all things architecture related make
sure you hit that subscribe button